[Music]
[Applause]
why do i record this in the morning
i don't know pewdiepie submissions
you're ready for some cringe
bets it's all cringe in here i'm
actually curious
what we're gonna get now cyber intro
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
old
now measure your peeps
[Music]
anyway he found juan wait juan isn't
real it's a fake horse
are you serious juan isn't real then
what's the point
i wrote this song for juan
[Music]
okay pewdiepie and marzia i'm getting
bored of pewdiepie videos
you're getting bored of pewdiepie videos
not carson god dang it
it's time for everyone's favorite part
of the video sponsor time
i know you're sitting like this right
now
nordvpn the greatest vpn of all time
nerdvpn helps you interact with the
internet safely
and epically need i say anything else
i will i use nordvpn it's a great
service
it's fast it's easy and you feel
protected
right now they have an amazing offer
where you get get this
68 off your two year plan of nordvpn
but you also get now four months for
free
this offer is available for limited time
only so now is a great time to order
nordvpn
they also have a 30 day money back
guarantee so you can try it out
if you don't like it which you want just
30 day money back to take control of
your internet experience today
with nordvpn completely risk free and
four months for free
right now use the link in the
description and the code pewdiepie
and start browsing safely today now back
to video
hey hello here
[Music]
nice
step on yes
holy [ __ ] hey
yes oh [ __ ]
yes god
damn that deserves an old upload on its
own dude
cursed animations took four months
damn yo go sub the curse only got 86
subs go sub
that was incredible cannot understate
the size of that pp
god damn martial check what's that
thumbnail
big creepy it's got it all 2015
[ __ ] you no [ __ ] you 20 20. you like
anime yeah i love it
we're gonna have to brawl it out we're
gonna have to fight in 2025. i challenge
you cave science
no i don't no i don't that was a joke
don't even
even slightly take that as real no i
don't want to die
rare footage of ceiling gang freaking
wait this is not this is a i got this in
my recommended
this is some dude that likes to climb
and
which honestly is pretty cringe
not gonna watch a second more oh you
made the sonar
oh damn that looks sick dude insane
oh see he does a bunch of masks that's
cool huge peepee
so i last video i i asked for you guys
help because we're making a music video
and it'd be cool to get
some of the props made by you guys plus
it will
save us some budget on christmas day i'm
going to be
posting my hardcore prawn
scythe oh my god that's disgusting where
yes i've yeah pewdiepie has been added
to the nice list
oh [ __ ] santa's gonna get cancelled
he you can't add pewdiepie on the nice
list
but it got so high
bye bye santa no santa this year
pewdiepie says he's losing all revenue
from a 30 minute video because he played
an unrecognized book celine dion cover
yes thank you music companies
for being so [ __ ] annoying but they
said they were playing the song it
sounded like this
oh better copyright that that did kind
of sound like my song
so [ __ ] dumb i'm honored to be army
general of the nine-year-old army
i'm ready to host meme review i am blue
shirt kid oh it's just cake day
oh a little cringe
i'll say it i'll say it i don't give a
[ __ ] how felix proposed to
mercy oh
no don't show this to her please please
for the love of god a small pp don't
show this
martial don't check what that
bandicam after inventing pewdiepie
wait people pay for bandicam
i love instagram that's where i find
good memes
not ready the entire reddit i feel
better
oh no oh god
i am so sorry
for my misjudgement i owe you guys
better
i'm so sad i can't open my eyes they are
literally locked shut do you not see how
remorseful i am
hey how long ago since my last apology
video
ah can we get some shout out can we get
a medal
i think i deserved something been a good
boy your meme gets into a pewdiepie
video
is
ah they're equally esteemed
come on they're cringed regardless right
case sign pewdiepie doing music jtfx
yeah i find it funny jd has multiple
albums
hit singles
[Laughter]
but he can't play the outboard to save
his life
he was literally screaming in it you're
supposed to blow
case i why are you still using ben it
came kind of stupid in it
my heart how could you say that no
it really breaks my heart with that
accent too it just hurts too much
six-year-old me after saying bad morning
instead of good morning to the teacher
you guys did they
ah that's savage dude that that unlocks
a memory in my brain that i forgot i had
when i was like six years old
i had this fake plastic tongue it was
really long
i remember exactly how it tasted like
that's weird
we would have to say good morning to the
teacher every morning
outside of the schoolyard and i thought
all right well this time
this is going to be hilarious i'm going
to wear the fake tongue and i'm going to
say good morning
and i i remember her reaction was like
oh
that's so cool or something like that
and now i realize she didn't think it
was cool she was just
patronizing me because i was a child
yeah
yeah it took me 24 years but i thank you
yeah what the
hell feuds in case i play titanic theme
terribly as a joke a random copy strike
company mine
mine all day a mine all nine
yeah it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] isn't it
for some random company that sounded
like my
song better strike it
joel sent me this look the office joe
cost
the series sixty thousand dollars they
had to pay a company
sixty thousand dollars because they
referenced a line
in a song those are the words i said in
my song you have to pace
sixty thousand because uh
why why exactly so it's just music too
right now you take a photo of yourself
and then some [ __ ] [ __ ] comes
that house is my house you have to pay
me now
take a photo of the ocean i own that
part of that ocean you have to pay
delete the photo the i own the photo now
mine
it's mine now oh it's so dumb
god damn wait is that bandy came
oh saw ksi having panda cammy when his
video
oh that's interesting oh that's a very
all right what else you got there huh
you better not have fraps in there oh is
that
internet explorer
you didn't unpin explorer from your task
bar
what is this 2012 hello 19 year old
in the last video peter said he needed
armor i do hell yeah
let my people talk to you people let's
make it happen
yeah i appreciate you guys uh being
invested in this i think that's fun
yeah yeah hell yeah some magneto [ __ ] i
love it
oh damn it's made out of that gym
material
hey cause i are you drinking monster
that's illegal
you drink g fuel you drink you look at
me
you're you drink g film now i think i
commented oh they said yes nice
ew i accepting sh pewdiepie should play
with
x because i want them to
i appreciate that guys i appreciate that
i just want to collab with felix
schelberg but he won't
return my texts [ __ ] hate him
oh damn look at jack dude
god damn right this is just offline t oh
okay mr beast and
corpse yeah damn course looks sick
women with a time machine
i am your granddaughter really men with
time machine
here take this slab king don't use my
pottery plate okay thanks
that was weird oh that's great that was
actually funny
cookie in the hat nice job people who
make it into law
have their own public toilet wow we're
finally
recognized by the government
whoever made that illustration well done
well done you should be proud of
yourself
you could become any profession in the
world any job
and you did this yes
guy almost breaks his ribs while lifting
weights
listen i saw that and it was so shocking
that the only reaction i could do was to
laugh come on it's what is a spotter
doing there he's just like
oh what
oh god french helix
finally felix
i mean that is kind of cool though with
the waves and
yeah i'm not french though get out of
isn't all bad watch this video i'm doing
a pruning
hey simon where you at currently adding
the tape
you had it for me and my only time
your simply has gone too far actually
you know what
i'll pardon this one yeah yeah you can
do this one scythe
that's okay that's okay i know how much
this means to you
i understand fears outer then click like
to die instantly as always
stay awesome fears after not long ago
like subscribe and all that crap i'll
see you guys tomorrow
here's after now look at grip guys it's
free
and subscribe and it's really important
for subscribers
here's my new outro
that's the white theme song what what
dude's telling everyone to buy a
pewdiepie edition phone case that's
right
hell yeah still available rhinoshield
dot io
me owns a phone that nobody makes cases
for anymore what the [ __ ] you got it
i was thinking these cases are so strong
imagine putting one of these
on a nokia 3310 that would be
a weapon of mass destruction i'm pretty
sure it's illegal
it would be too powerful literally
anyone in the gym
will show you how to use anything me but
that's social interaction
and i don't support it they will stay
[ __ ]
sorry yeah
hey i like this it's boomer pewdiepie
those [ __ ] kids and those tick tocks
man it's hella cringe
kids play fortnite these days that's so
cringe
people review the pewdiepie submissions
reddit that is so cringe
one brave here but hey finally someone
used a g-field template
nice you finally found it
i approve another celebrity life ruined
by drugs and alcohol
nah too much g fuel feud's when he
convinced jaden not to
kill him in the security room that was
so funny i love that i want to play more
hide and seek among it the negotiations
were short and quite successful dudes
every single comment is unfunny me
understanding he just wants to be a good
husband
tg man i'm sorry tg
man 12. i did you dirty man i did you
dirty
this video is sponsored by pewdiepie
store shut up
everyone does this come on why do i only
get
four right well
but why you know i would never explain
his name if i got mad
no oh come on don't show me that
it's too painful of a memory i don't
want to look at that
yes you've seen juan but have you seen
pablo
[Music]
i was going to play us and
i am 30 years old
i strain my connect neck gang pathetic
[Laughter]
dude i've been doing these shoulder
lifts
to work out my neck every day
my neck is going to be strong man oh i
feel it dude this is good
gonna dislocate my shoulder irish
pewdiepie
and swedish except the guy is suspenders
give me the right
oh
you got to make yourself big it's like a
bear you got to like scare it away
oh my voice is also large
yep
[Applause]
[Music]
they have the finest porsche
i'm not scared of ghosts
[Music]
are you in here you son of a [ __ ] yep
okay okay that's cool epic come on
that's great look at grip look at grant
it's an episode
look at graph look at the graph this
video based sponsored
check it out the finest clothing on the
planet
it's all made from scratch it's not
printed on blanks no
cheap [ __ ] producing portugal
pre-washed so it won't shrink baby
go to base.gigi.com no wait
go to base.gd no oh all right that's the
video thanks for watching guys
brofist see you tomorrow looking for
some high
level gaming gear check out face okay
but of what
top scientists have determined that
wearing base gear makes you a better
gamer
with at least two percent basis for
everyone no matter what level you're at
but you need to be at least six eight to
order which i am of course
you have before december 11th to place
your order
and solidify your place in the gaming
history booths
so what are you waiting for buff up your
wardrobe today and head over to base.gg
basil i'm 68 i swear
can i order